my father was 19 my mother was 21 when
they got married
they eloped
30
33 days after hi nice to meet you
meeting each other
are they narcissists
one would only imagine um
the
the the whole like
teach your kids not to have sex before
marriage makes horny kids
that's all it does yes sorry he's not
sorry
um but so you know my parents want to
get laid um
that's my take on it um nine months
later my older sister was born
two years and two months later i was
born 15 months later my little sister
was born so within a high nice to meet
you
to four years later three kids
and some mid-20s
you know adults if you want to call them
adults in their mid-20s because i
certainly know that i am barely an adult
in my mid-30s i am with you i remember
a hundred years ago i got married and i
was like oh my god like i was 23 and i'm
like oh yeah i'm not even close to the
same person
i mean the 20s are
right the first 18 years of your life
you're you're
expanding into an adult you're literally
your bones are growing your your
heights everything's growing
then you are legally termed an adult by
government
agencies right you're 18 so now you're
technically recognized as an adult your
brain then those the neuroscience
community wouldn't recognize you as you
as an adult because the brain doesn't
even finish structurally
structurally developing until 25.
so
so the government's all like you an
adult at 18 and the neuroscience
community is like wow i don't know about
that and then of course our plasticity
i'm a little bit of a nerd just i mean
that's all the time neuroplasticities
all the time no you go nerd out on me
i i was thinking to myself i'm i'm
slipping this in but when you were you
were out in arizona and i was like oh
let's get together
because i had heard you talking about i
think it was about your podcast saying
like that your role is like i love all
the shamans and the woo-woo and the
spiritual i was like oh my god let's
have a woo-woo off let's see who's more
let's do it together oh my god i'm
looking my flight back to arizona yeah
and i love i love um quantum physics and
i love
um
anything that has to do with the mind
and reality so neuroplasticity all of
that and the power of it you just keep
wording it out
okay well i'll admit i was a little i
was two minutes late logging on here
because i had lost track of time
listening to jodo spenza on his uh live
pod he does this live expo with gaia the
streaming network oh that's cool i just
finally signed up for gaia joe's great
i've interviewed him too he's
he's really oh my god you've interviewed
him oh yeah yeah i've interviewed him
i've done a couple i've did his
week-long retreat i did a one day in
santa barbara last fall with him um and
like 18 people
uh where do you live i'm just gonna come
move in with you yeah yeah you should
i'm alone i hang out in your energy
field it's the whole zen area trust me
trust me okay okay we're good we're
already best friends but we're
having a what is i don't know what they
call a girl crush we're having girl
crushers right now um
but yeah so so that i'm a nerd i love
joe dispenza i love quantum physics all
these things started to come to me in my
healing journey but that started at age
25 for me and at this point i had this
crazy life moment so the segments of my
life continuing there was the new york
point at 18 i moved to los angeles
as a technical adult
and i you know at this point and i had
lived a lot of life because of all the
things i've been through but when you're
18 years old
you do not have the luxury of time
experience
experience moving through space and time
as joe dispenza would say
space and time allow you to see seasons
seasons allow you to realize that things
end and they begin again rebirth and
renewal for every winter there's a
spring right and this this aspect of
ourselves that we get to experience when
we have life experience
is the cyclic aspect of life
and
unfortunately trauma kids we don't get a
childhood so we are made to either act
like adults we feel like we have to be
adults we're panicked so we're acting
like adults out of just shared reaction
to our circumstances survival mechanisms
kicking in
we feel older than we are
and yet we haven't seen the cyclic
experiences of life where things live
die and repeat right
yeah and the patterns the patterns yeah
so
so that whole experience for me was i
taken this you know the kool-aid that
was put in my sippy cup and i drank all
that [ __ ] and then i like started
filling up my own bottles with it and i
really really thought that whole arrival
theory fallacy
i really thought
in this unthought known where it wasn't
something i consciously thought of but i
had the sense because of everything that
was ingrained in me from society culture
and all the above
that once i became an actress
you couldn't [ __ ] not see me anymore
right one side dot dot dot
and
that's that hit me like a ton of bricks
because
still
no one [ __ ] cared
no one cared at least from my outlook
again at that time in that age no one
cared that i was having to smile on red
carpets while i'm cutting my arms up at
home in the bathtub and wanting to kill
myself and just barely not killing
myself up until a point when i did
attempt and and that that made me feel
so much more invisible because now i was
being told you did it you're a success
oh my god you made it and and it was
like
oh oh wow this actually never
i'm never gonna be okay like
i got the thing that was supposed to
make it okay and it's so not okay and
i'm even more invisible now being seen
by everyone
than i was when i was this kid who just
thought maybe you know
like somebody in the community could
could have seen me and helped well
that's just a perfect example of how
no one can fix you no thing can fix you
no destination no job no
no thing can fix you but you
and so
from to mirror like to show you
people did see you i saw you i mean [ __ ]
girl i love fired up okay i heard i
heard you talking about that you were
the mean girl cheerleader but it was
actually the other way around which is
very interesting but anyway i mean i saw
you many people saw you so it was
happening but if you don't feel it for
yourself if you can't give it to
yourself and so much of that work has to
do with the inner child and seeing the
inner child
that's what i've found in my own work in
my own sort of like big epiphanies and
healing like mom trauma dad trauma
is that it wasn't until i started seeing
myself and taking care of my inner child
and taking care of that original wound
spot right
about like going back in time to that
little girl and what happened that made
her the way she was or him the way he
was and it's like taking care of that
kid it's not some something it's not a
destination yeah
it's an inside job and it's
you know it's an inside job it's exactly
all an inside job so how how the hell
did you get to the inside like what was
it that helped you realize that um
no no destination was gonna get you
there no job no no tv show no movie
nothing
well that leads me to actually answer
your original question which was what
was the impetus of all of this you know
this coming to uh this awareness of even
just yesterday this moment with selling
the bed and not selling it and being
able to give it to someone who's going
to repurpose it um i got to repurpose my
life
and
in the process
of realizing actually fired up was a
catalyst for me to repurpose my life for
the first time
i was being offered 90210 while i was on
fired up
nip tuck was the show that i was
technically still filming but we were in
a writer's strike and everything had
frozen in time obviously because we'd
run out of scripts and we couldn't the
writers couldn't write anymore so i had
some off time i was able to do fired up
and
in that but in that writer's strike a
film on human trafficking that i was
obsessed with i was so adamant that i
was gonna do this film i was so excited
i met with the directors multiple times
um
[Music]
they were in the middle rewrites and it
got shelved and the money pulled out and
the film didn't happen and i was just
heartbroken and i was on fired up and it
was supposed to be such a fun setting
you know and it was literally just
i didn't go to high school as i
mentioned but it was high school [ __ ]
going on and i just really didn't
understand how i literally went to shake
the the other lead actress's hand and
she like was holding her little sidekick
and looks up at me like
ew you're the other cheerleader i'm like
um no [ __ ] i'm an actress playing a
cheerleader and also hi i'm anil and
shake my [ __ ] hand um
and it was just this like
the same range yeah i was like you're
going to stream don't look away i'm like
um
not gonna let you um it was so weird and
then i got over to my group uh we were
training for a couple weeks of these you
know we had cheer practice for two weeks
before we started filming you know i did
all anyone that doesn't know
fired up is a cheerleading movie it's
the best it's hilarious it's so funny
it's seriously one of my top
top five favorite movies oh my god i'm
so glad you feel that way it actually it
did turn out so funny the guys on there
eric and nick they're so hysterical
dialogue is so good it's like it's like
the best funny dialogue movie and this
was like will glucks the director write
director he was like his first thing
like big big deal thing and he um he was
he was awesome but he you know went on
to do special eye and all those other
things but um but this one he's he's
just he's got that dry wit you know and
um but yeah the experience was just like
really really vapid very and
what do you expect right you put a bunch
of 20 somethings together in a makeup
hair trailer and they are you know being
they're on a big sony film and it's the
start of their life and again as the
neuroscience community would say
they haven't fully developed their
brains yet we can't be upset with them
um and and i've actually had
conversations with some of the actresses
who like i'm really sorry that that was
kind of weird back then i'm like
no worries we were child we were
literally kids
but because of the experience
in the moment losing that film or you
know it not happening the one about
human trafficking and this this this
movie that i just was like
surrounded by all this like you know
egotistical
vapid energy
i just was
like what if i
decided to do with my life talk about
your inner child i reached out to my
nine-year-old inner child it's like you
were
really off the mark lady like why did
you want to be an actress this was a
stupid idea and she's like should have
been an archaeologist like you thought
yes i wanted to be an archaeologist
before that you should have been an
archaeologist damn it um
my nine-year-old self was like you'll
catch up
stupid girl my nine-year-old self is way
wiser than me
um
but so our inner child's always super
wise very simple very clear but usually
very wise extremely wise i defer to her
at all at all times at all costs like
it's just like where are you please help
but so does your inner child have a name
have you given your inner child name
little anna i call her a little little
anna um because i'm anna lynn and so
she's little anna um but yeah so so
that this particular period
put me in the
i'm fast forwarding a lot but all of it
culminated to the point where i was
in a place where i realized i have my
what i've had my what since i was nine
years old what i wanted to do in the
world i wanted to be an actress this is
what i wanted to do why
why did i want to do this i didn't know
i didn't know that i felt invisible i
didn't know that i needed to be seen my
little inner child and i like i said we
were more at odds at the time she was
kind of like i don't trust you and i was
kind of like i'm smarter than you um so
it was just you know two inner children
one wasn't an adult one was acting from
an adult body the other was just like
bad girl um
so that point happened
then i
my
very good friend who's my first acting
partner in new york jessica menhas who's
the founder and ceo of i'll go first
which is an incredible platform for
trauma survivors and individuals who
have gone through really horrific things
to come and tell their story and go
first because she and i realized in the
work that we do
taking shame out of the room was a big
part of what we had to do and and it
required us to go first because shame
just
it's it's an illusion right it literally
it's like
it's like a dark room you turn on the
light one person turns on the switch and
everybody can see
and so
one person turns on that light and shame
just evaporates like the darkness in a
room with a light on